[Música]
lagos
quem que brincou com ela na infância e
vocês mulheres brincaram
como vocês podem perceber eu não e tudo
que eu mais queria era poder brincar com
jogos educativos que me permitissem
construir qualquer coisa que os livros
me ensinavam a sonhar
eu sou uma pessoa extremamente nas
técnicas eu gosto de pôr a mão na massa
eu gosto de cozinhar eu gosto de
construir e montar o quebra cabeça
outro dia eu comprei um jogo de mesa e
cadeira lá pra casa e vem desmontado e
eu falei eu vou montar
levei dois dias no final do segundo dia
eu não conseguia fechar mãos tanto
parafusar eu acho o máximo com a galera
lá em casa fala tá vendo eu que montei e
ninguém caiu até hoje mas infelizmente a
gente ainda vive numa sociedade que
divide em azul para meninos e rosa para
meninas e natal só o meu irmão ganhava
lábios
naquela época eu ainda nem sabia o que
era privilégio
falando nisso vocês já pararam para
refletir sobre a existência ou
inexistência dos privilégios na vida de
vocês como que isso reflete no dia a dia
de vocês e das pessoas ao seu redor
vamos fazer o seguinte eu tenho uma
proposta de uma brincadeira rápida para
fazer com vocês por favor tirem tudo que
estava perto e eu vou pedir pra vocês
quer dizer eu pedi uma das instruções e
ficar de pé
então se vocês puderem tirar das mesas
para ficarem livres e bem rapidinho eu
prometo que não vai doer
eu vou fazer algumas perguntas se a
resposta para essa pergunta fosse eu
peço que por favor vocês fiquem de pé aí
vocês então e assim por diante
quem é que possui plano de saúde
por favor fique de pé pode sentar
quem é que estuda ou estudou em escolas
particulares
por favor fique de pé pode sentar
quem aqui já ganhou um carro dos pais
por favor fique de pé
obrigada e por fim só para reflexão
quem aqui estaria hoje nesse evento
se não fossem os seus privilégios eu com
certeza não estaria
mas essa certeza que eu tenho hoje aqui
estou compartilhando com vocês agora me
custou a chegar
eu lembro que em 2011 num no último
semestre da faculdade de direito no
cesusc uma faculdade particular de
florianópolis
eu me dei conta que apesar de não ter
nascido em berço de ouro
ao longo da minha trajetória eu tive
acesso a oportunidades que várias
pessoas do meu círculo familiar meu
círculo de amizade de colegas não
tiveram
e eu lembro de conversar com uma colega
de classe
alguém que eu sempre admirei muito pela
sua determinação pela sua força de
vontade
você é uma aluna é extraordinária e pôr
assim como eu tenho uma vontade muito
grande de mudar o mundo de construir
deixar um legado positivo para a
sociedade
naquela época eu fazia parte de uma
organização internacional ingerida
apenas por jovens que têm como missão
nada mais que mudar o mundo e buscar a
paz
eu achava o máximo fazer parte daquela
organização e tem a oportunidade de
viajar o mundo e conhecer outros países
outras culturas realizar intercâmbios
internacionais culturais corporativos e
voluntariado
eu lembro de chegar pra saber colega e
conversar com ele fala cara porque te
inscreve para esse programa tem
exatamente o perfil que eles estão
buscando é inteligente determinada tem
um coração gigante tem vontade de fazer
voluntariado na áfrica não é isso
bolatti inscreve eu vou falar eu faço
questão de falar de ti eu tenho certeza
que você vai passar sem problema nesse
processo seletivo
eu lembro que ela me olhou com carinho
a diferença e falou assim ela adoraria
fazer trabalho voluntário
só que o trabalho voluntário requer
tempo
eu faço dois estágios 1 de manhã e de
tarde para ajudar a pagar as contas no
fim do mês
a gente tem aula à noite ele tem que
arranjar tempo para estudar para
garantir que a minha média que você
atinge a média que por sinal é maior que
a média da faculdade porque eu sou
bolsista e eu não posso me dar ao luxo
de perder minha bolsa
naquele momento o meu mundo caiu e caiu
porque eu aprecio aprende e percebi que
mudar o mundo requer muito mais do que
boa vontade com o coração mudar o mundo
requer demanda recursos como tempo
dinheiro que nunca foram distribuídos em
pé de igualdade
ali o filme é um compromisso comigo
mesmo a buscar mais sobre o que é
privilégio a ser mais conscientes sobre
os meus privilégios sobre o que eu faço
com eles durante muito tempo inclusive
sentir culpa por ser uma pessoa
privilegiada vivendo em um mundo tão
dolorosamente desigual mas eu fui atrás
de respostas de conceitos de histórias
de exemplos de privilégio diz privilégio
apoiado encorajada pela minha mentora
pelos meus amigos meus colegas e eu
comecei a pesquisar a respeito e sempre
que tinha oportunidade a começar essa
discussão onde passava
no ano passado eu estava morando nos
estados unidos
eu fazia parte de uma organização
internacional também que me dá a
oportunidade de ter acesso a uma rede de
contatos internacionais extremamente
adversa gente do mundo todo de
diferentes culturas religiões etnias
escolaridade e eu vi naquela
oportunidade à possibilidade perfeita de
conversar com essas pessoas sobre o que
é privilégio e eu os convidei para uma
dinâmica conhecida como você talvez já
tenho visto aí na internet chamada a
caminhada do privilégio e algo muito
parecido com o que eu fiz com vocês
ainda pouco
é como se fosse
a corrida em que todo mundo começa em pé
de igualdade
afinal todos nós somos iguais não é
mesmo mas como vocês devem imaginar
alguns têm mais facilidade para chegar
ao fim dessa corrida do que outros
a instrução é simples eu faço uma
pergunta
dependendo da sua resposta você vai pra
frente ou você vai pra trás
após essa dinâmica eu sentei com a
galera ea gente conversou sobre as suas
experiências ea conversa foi tão gostosa
e tão rica que aquilo ali me gerou uma
curiosidade ainda maior e eu quis fazer
um proveito ainda maior também daquela
minha rede de contatos que agora não
eram só aquelas pessoas que participaram
daquela daquela atividade eram também as
pessoas que essas pessoas conheceram e
aí eu criei um formulário digital bem
simples e distribuir na minha rede com
batom aí facebook e mail whatsapp e
assim por diante
essa pesquisa teve 101 respondentes de
22 países diferentes sendo que 77 por
cento dos respondentes foram mulheres e
23% foram homens
uma das curiosidades dessa pesquisa foi
eu não limitei o tipo de resposta a
todas as perguntas que eu fiz eu deixei
aberto para que as pessoas respondessem
como elas se sentem como ela se
identificam como elas representam se
sentem representadas
então por exemplo em matéria de
orientação sexual
ao invés de simplesmente colocar as
opções que a gente está acostumado a ver
pela sociedade heterossexual homossexual
gay ou lésbica e bissexual teve um
universo colorido de todas as
possibilidades e eu aprendi que 2% das
pessoas se consideram simplesmente
fluidas mente aberta e eu achei lindo
quanto à etnia por também deixar aberto
eu percebi quão diverso e novamente
lindo
é um universo que a gente vive quando a
gente não
pula as pessoas e diminuir esses óculos
como na hora de fazer a inscrição do
vestibular em que brancos negros e
mestiços e índios talvez seja isso que
vai encontrar essas foram as pessoas que
participaram os perfis de respondentes
dessa pesquisa
quando perguntado se alguma vez já se
viram uma situação de desprivilegiado
56% e disse que sim e aí eu isolei esse
grupo para analisar cada uma de suas
respostas e eu comecei a buscar quais
foram as palavras as situações que mais
se repetiram nessas pessoas que já
passaram por situação de privilégio
eu aprendi que as maiores situações de
privilégio de acordo com esse grupo de
pessoas estava relacionado na ordem em
gênero situação econômica financeira
social e etnia
eu confesso que isso não foi uma
surpresa pra mim como também não foi uma
surpresa perceber que 8% desses
respondentes se disseram se não se
consideram pessoas privilegiadas quente
a gente vive numa sociedade desigual e
cheio de injustiças acreditar que todo
mundo é privilegiado o que todo mundo se
considera privilegiado
seria ilusão ou ingenuidade minha
surpresa veio quando eu comecei a ler as
respostas dessas pessoas que se dizem
não privilegiados algumas foi fácil
entender quando eu associei aos seus
perfis
mas outros deixaram curiosa
houve quem falasse de privilégio como
meritocracia
só uma pessoa privilegiada
assim no berço de ouro e tudo que eu fiz
tudo que eu tenho eu fiz por merecer
eu também eu ao ano
mas eu tenho noção que se não fossem os
meus privilégios eu não teria tido
acesso às mesmas oportunidades que eu
tive que me trouxeram aqui hoje um
conceito ou uma resposta de privilégio
que me chamou muita atenção foi a
seguinte
eu vou pedir licença para ler pra vocês
o privilégio pra esse respondente é um
termo de esquerda utilizado para desviar
a atenção das substâncias dos argumentos
de sua origem imediata
esse é o mundo que vivemos há quem
acredite que privilégio não existe mas
enfim eu tô aqui falam de privilégio
privilégio trazendo dados e nenhum
momento eu estabeleci 11 uma base né
afinal de contas é isso que eu estava
buscando a minha pesquisa que eu busco
até hoje eu continuo falando sobre esse
assunto
afinal o que é privilégio
o dicionário aurélio vai nos dizer que o
privilégio o direito vantagem concedido
a alguém com exclusão de outros
com base nas respostas da pesquisa
eu criei esse chamado word cloud uma
nuvem de palavras e as palavras que
vocês vêem maior são as palavras que
mais apareceram nas respostas das
pessoas
então eu pensei bom que acordo com essas
pessoas o privilégio é algo muito
parecido com o aurélio fala privilégio é
isso pressupõe uma relação entre pelo
menos duas pessoas ou dois grupos
diferentes uma relação de equiparação em
pé desigualdade que geralmente resulta
em injustiça nas minhas conversas eu
aprendi com a isabel
uma amiga minha jovem branca americana
de classe média que pra ela privilégio é
o fato dela ser como eu já escrevi poder
na verdade vestir sair na rua vestindo
um moletom com capuz na cabeça e ser
considerada no máximo desleixada
essa não é a realidade do seu irmão raúl
matou o irmão adotivo da etiópia que por
ser negro se vestir
o moletom com capuz na cabeça para
muitas pessoas especialmente no bairro
onde eles moram em um bairro
majoritariamente branco pode ser visto
como um sinal de ameaça
eu continuo buscando respostas sobre
privilégio conceitos definições e eu
continuo conversando com pessoas a esse
respeito mas de todas as respostas de
todas as definições maior aprendizado
que eu tive até hoje surgiu numa
conversa numa reunião de trabalho em que
um dos meus chefes que também é
professor debate bastante sobre
privilégios com seus alunos lá nos
estados unidos
ele falou o que importa é o conceito de
de privilégio
o que importa é o que fazemos com isso
para o daniel ou dengue como a gente
costuma falar
o maior privilégio de todos é sabermos
quando nos é conveniente ou não
utilizarmos os nossos privilégios
meu nome é ana sousa e eu sou uma pessoa
privilegiada e eu vim aqui hoje para
fazer um convite a vocês pra vocês
olharem e refletirem sobre privilégios
de uma forma diferente
que privilégio não mais seja sinônimo de
desigualdade e injustiça social que
vocês possam ver os seus privilégios
como essa pecinhas de lego que cada um
de vocês recebeu vocês não escolheram
receber essa peça você sequer sabiam que
iriam receber essa peça você não tiver a
oportunidade de escolher seu tamanho cor
ou modelo
você simplesmente receberam e vocês
podem fazer o que quiser com elas
inclusive negar a sua existência ou
simplesmente jogar fora o final do
evento
você assim como lego podem construir o
que quiser
eu deixo esse convite construam
construir um sonho que vocês aprenderam
a sonhar com os livros que vocês leram
na infância construam espaços seguros
para que a gente possa ter conversas
significativas onde a gente possa
aprender mais um com o outro e nos
ensine a ser mais tolerantes e
respeitosos com as nossas diferenças e
construir um meio de transporte que nos
leve da nossa zona de conforto para a
zona de conforto do outro
construam pontes que nos permita
vez as barreiras à desigualdade social
do preconceito e da discriminação
construiu escolas construam parques
construir hospitais construir o nosso
futuro
só não construam muros muito obrigada
[Aplausos]